[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight
joe biden has not waded too deeply into
questions of public policy recently in
case you haven't noticed
whatever else biden may be doing looking
at funny cat videos on the internet
shuffling to his mailbox every afternoon
it's fair to say that he is not running
a campaign about ideas
but biden has made at least one campaign
promise so far
he's pledged that if elected he will
force you to wear a mask when you go
outside
now biden didn't specify which
epidemiological studies would justify
a law like that that's probably because
there aren't any
not a single one but whatever biden has
never been much of
a science guy he is a lifelong
politician his specialty is not public
health
his specialty is power and coercion so
he does what he knows
instead of explaining how wearing a mask
when you ride your bike alone could
possibly save
anyone's life biden instead demands that
you forget about your so-called rights
as an american and obey his orders
no questions allowed otherwise you're
unpatriotic
if it sounds familiar that's because
we've seen a lot of this lately
democrats have decided to use our public
health emergency
as a political weapon to win the
election
turns out that's easier than trying to
fix the country
terrified unhappy populations want
change and that's welcome news to the
party trying to take
power that's why they're doing it but
what's the cost to the rest of us to
america
it's profound thanks to restrictions
that are rooted in politics rather than
science
children cannot go to school or play
with their friends parents can't go to
work
people can't get married or attend
funerals
human contact has been drastically
curtailed these are not small things
they're essential human needs without
them we can't live
in may we talk to a father whose teenage
son killed himself he believes because
of isolation caused by the chronovirus
lockdowns
it was a crushing segment and hard to
watch but it's worth watching
here's part of the conversation
my my young 12 year old boy three days
before his 13th birthday
uh took his life uh hayden was a
normal kid he wasn't depressed he died
of the covert virus he didn't die of the
cold virus but he died certainly because
of the covert virus
the isolation has created what i believe
in what i worry and what i'm warning
every parent in america tonight
an emotional tsunami is sweeping this
nation
um and i'm very concerned about it
he had reason to be very concerned about
it that was nearly three months ago the
country has become
sadder and more isolated since in fact
the lockdowns have driven americans to
the edge and that's not speculation
according to new data from the cdc fully
a quarter of
all young people in this country between
18 and 24
recently have considered suicide
seriously thought about killing
themselves
that is a massive and terrifying
increase over previous surveys
it's a tragedy anxiety and depression
are record highs many americans have
fallen into a spiral from which they
will not escape
because of coronavirus many people are
now unemployed or isolated at home
and as a result the drug epidemic has
intensified
you shoot up you smoke you do whatever
it is you do pop a pill
and the world goes away for a while joe
cordovano runs fresh start ministries in
orlando
and says they're seeing more relapses
and more stories of drug abuse as a
result
nationwide it's the same story the
national institute on drug abuse
estimates that since the outbreak
overdoses are up between 30 and 40
percent
people are depressed you see it all
around you they're depressed because
they're cut off
from one another they're depressed
because their lives are moving backwards
according to data collected last month
12 of american households in the richest
country in the world
are now routinely short on food more
than 20 percent of all renters
in america are behind on payments keep
in mind these data were collected before
federal unemployment benefits expired
people are abandoning their pets
prescriptions are going
unfilled we could go on big parts of
this country are becoming poor
but you don't hear about it much because
to the media
and our leaders in washington it's not a
very big deal they can't imagine
worrying about money in washington they
live in a city with guaranteed full
employment
always and forever thanks to the federal
government and it affects their
attitudes
here's tony fauci the most political man
in the most political city in america
telling you that going broke isn't
really a big deal
i know it's difficult but we're having a
lot of suffering a lot of death
this is inconvenient from an economic
and a personal standpoint
but we just have to do it
it's inconvenient says dr fauci
remember when you respected that guy
remember when he seemed like a
legitimate public health expert we do
he was on the show we treated him like a
physician
now it's clear fauci is just another
oily politician on an ego trip just like
the rest of them
in case you haven't been to a
supermarket recently fauci is featured
on the cover of
instyle magazine photographed by the
pool
man of science what a buffoon
but fauci isn't suffering during the
lockdowns he's loving it
tony fauci is enjoying the hell out of
himself
so is cnn jeff zucker understands that
the lockdowns are the only way his
personal friend carmela harris is ever
going to run the country
so his anchors dutifully berate the
public for not obeying
even as they ignore the rules they
demand that you follow
watch the bodybuilders roid rants on the
subject
all right so while most americans are
staying inside or should be
right if they're not out protesting like
fools they're not happy about being told
to stay home
staying home saves lives and the rest of
us should be staying at home
for our mothers and the people that we
love and to keep us
farther apart will ultimately bring us
closer together in this cause
our collective conscientious actions
staying home
stay home that's the order except of
course when you're pledging allegiance
to the democratic party
and in that case feel free to flood the
streets it's healthy
in new york city for example local
politicians gathered in front of trump
tower to paint black lives matter
on the street social distancing was not
required even though bill de blasio
showed up high as a kite as usual
and did his best to make a straight line
jeff zucker didn't complain of course
the media loved it
but keep in mind not all public
gatherings are equally safe some are
incredibly dangerous it's hard to know
the difference unless you're politically
attuned
in new york the city just announced it
will not commemorate 9 11
as it always does this year the
traditional twin beams of light over
manhattan will be
dark next month why because officials
say they can't risk the safety of the
crews they would need to set up the
memorial
turning on two lights is just too
dangerous
right now there's a pandemic out there
do you take them at their word
do you think that's the real problem
come on you know what's going on
anything that brings people together
that unites us
as a nation that gives people pride in
their country
must be stopped anything that causes
division
fear panic anxiety hatred
must be amplified no matter how many
kids kill themselves as a result there's
an election coming up
here's dr biden explaining the rules if
our president today
i would roll back the reopenings in a
number of places and
everyone wherever there is a significant
percentage of people with covet should
be required to keep social distancing
and mask bars should not be open there
should not be
congregations of more than 10 people
oh so after consulting with his advisors
all of them political advisors biden has
located the core of the problem it turns
out
america isn't shut down enough people
might be tempted to go to church or
have dinner with their friends or work
for a living
kids could wind up in school and learn
things that haven't been pre-screened by
google
somewhere a young couple might decide to
take a walk through the woods without
masks to enjoy nature and fresh air
and if things like that continue
happiness might return to america
we can't have that not until people
learn how to vote correctly